on the 8th of july 2021 amsterdam city
government adopted one of the most
ambitious environmental visions for a
city and the plans to achieve it in
history
the dutch government features one
central government divided over 12
provinces
beneath them are hundreds of individual
municipalities
municipalities can range from cities to
towns and they form a legislative body
with a plural executive
unlike many other countries
burkhammester's mayors are not elected
in the dutch system but sea elected and
they form a pseudo-executive branch with
vet outers who are appointed by the
khmentarat the legislative body
in 2021 the umhaving's visit roughly
translating into environmental vision
was passed
a somewhat vague document by dutch
standards it still sets out a detailed
plan for how the city can and will
develop over the next couple of decades
[Music]
amsterdam is separated into the
following burrows
the center being the most historically
famous for its canals red light district
and drunk british tourists
to balance the increasing pressure on
the center the city has focused in on
making the other boroughs more
attractive in themselves in new west
south oast in north amsterdam's largest
transformations are taking place
north located across the eye has been
seen as historically separate the
borough inconvenient to travel to
requiring either travel by ferry and
but in 2018 a metro connection made
north a focus point for urban
development in the city attracting
investment and gentrification
but the metro line and existing ferry
networks are not enough to weather the
increasing demand for public
transportation from the growing city
population especially when the city has
also committed to not increasing car
traffic
and to solve this the city has planned
for the construction of additional
bridges located at the center and on two
opposing flanks reducing the bottlenecks
on transportation and making north a
more desirable place to live
in all three boroughs the city is
planning on investing massively in
constructing higher dense areas in order
to create sub-centers within the overall
city in all three attempts at producing
more mixed residential and business
zoning so the city can attract more
middle class families
these high density areas are also
generally located close to
transportation nodes and the city will
also attempt to add regional hubs for
cars located near stations extending the
metro network reducing the maximum car
speed and adding additional bike paths
on the already existing network
but all of these changes are a
reflection of one major goal
increase the density across the entire
city converting sections of the city
into different islands of density which
pushes the focus outside the historic
center
and this is where a seeming
contradiction emerges how do you
increase houses while also trying to
increase the city's overall green space
like a deformed hand one of amsterdam's
most unique features are its green
wedges
large areas of green landscape that
tunnel their way into the city
providing in theory readily available
access to green space for everyone
in the early 1900s european city
planners investigated and debated how
the growth of a city could be balanced
with maintaining green spaces and
reducing sprawl and there were many
different ideas on how this could be
achieved
entire belts of green surrounding entire
cities implemented in large part in
england
or wedges which could also vary
significantly in how they were designed
the netherlands was one of the european
countries that pioneered the use of
green wedges and their connection to
amsterdam can be traced back to the
1920s to a vision by hendrick vaidevelt
a dutch graphic designer and architect
who proposed that the city should follow
a green wedge design in his works chaos
and order
dividing the outside of amsterdam into
different equal wedges which would
constrain chaos into clearly delineated
order
he also made elaborate plans for
people's theater which would be situated
in vuona park near amsterdam's main
cultural institutions and represent a
symbol of fertility welcoming the mass
of people designed as if they were small
seeds that aspire to reach the inside of
the theater space a real and true
maternal womb
it wasn't until around a decade later
though that a young architect cornelius
on a stream would actually end up making
the green wedges a reality for the city
von estrin worked for amsterdam's town
planning department for over 30 years as
well as serving as the chairman of cm
the international congress of modern
architecture but in a more complicated
french the organization that helped
influence the modernist principles and
architecture that inspired the belmer
three decades later which also deserves
a video of its own
influence behind the ideas of creating a
functional city from aesthetic produced
the amsterdam extension plan in the
1930s which introduced a network of
green wedges that would start in
amsterdam and then widen themselves out
into the green heart of the netherlands
a large green area that is sizing itself
up to become one of the most important
sections of the country maybe even
europe in its entirety over the coming
decades
many on the outside look at amsterdam in
isolation a single city with a rich
history that stands on its own
but this is wrong
netherlands
is
the international international
amsterdam is part of a much larger hole
the ronstat one of the most overlooked
metropolitan regions on earth
the fourth largest in europe only after
london paris and rain
it's an urban cluster of the netherlands
most economically valuable cities
including many other important
municipalities and townships
and where many cities across europe
stand individually pressure to expand
with little constraint outwards the
ronstalt is unique for being a cluster
of cities individually expanding within
incredibly close proximity with the
option to travel to multiple cities
within the cluster in under two hours
using public transport
the ronstadt area home to nearly half of
the country's population mirrors
amsterdam's individual problems a
growing pressure for new housing while
also maintaining high quality green
space
the ronstadt has put increasing
attention on how the huna heart should
be regulated and the landscape preserved
both for the residents living there and
also as a vital green space for the
people living on the outside of it
concern for this development which will
be under increasing scrutiny over the
next few decades has practically locked
expansion into the green wedges as the
amsterdam city government also has to
manage negotiating scarce public land
with other municipalities
instead they will continue to focus on
producing the high density areas in the
places already existing between each
wedge and on their borders while
attempting to make the wedges more
attractive for the pedestrians living
between them
one of the ways of doing this is by
targeting the highways that border them
which can constrain access
by converting business areas into mixed
residential zoning which brings in a
larger amount of city government revenue
the city government can then gather a
war chest that can be used to redevelop
the highways so they can provide more
green space and or better access to it
this is happening alongside millions in
investment for more green spaces in the
city overall
and although the plans are relatively
vague on how this will be achieved it's
clear that the goals are to link green
spaces in the city creating an
interconnected network while also making
street level changes directly
this means installing green roofs on the
homes that can handle it and replacing
tiles on sidewalks which for some reason
the dutch are obsessed with it i mean it
makes absolutely no sense but the green
is also necessary to solve a more
nefarious problem
rain
amsterdam has and will continue to see
more extreme weather which contributes
to flooding and to city damage
a way to solve this is by individually
equipping homes that together can solve
the larger problem
in front of older new buildings you can
make space for gardens with water-hungry
plants by getting rid of street tiling
then create subtle cuts and concrete a
design feature so simple that it's
genius connect the drains and then rig
it so that if the water supply is too
much for the dirt plant sponge it can
then filter through the larger city
drain and only then impact the water
network do this with enough homes and we
might have a chance for handling extreme
weather events
[Music]
the netherlands is a good country and
plenty of people know that the dutch are
good at water but much less know why the
dutch are also so good at being so
critical
[Music]
and that's because to maintain the
system that would defend them against
walls of death the dutch would require a
massive coordinated effort if you don't
critique your neighbor's dike building
abilities you die
and although history is always difficult
to draw trend lines through the culture
that had to be developed to maintain the
system has been connected with the
consensus structure that takes place in
all facets of dutch society including of
course the development of amsterdam and
so if you're interested in the future of
this city make sure you call up the
jementa and piss off the vet outers
because not only is that in your right
but they're also getting paid way too
much not to be criticized and at the end
of the day what amsterdam's plans
envision can be very different from what
is possible the corona crisis required a
large amount of the city's budget and
the most recently chosen coalition of
jesus incesto pepe
has to make some very difficult
decisions they can reduce their
ambitions by failing to deliver on their
infrastructure plans or they can attempt
to still get close to reaching their
goals by making the locals foot the bill
but what makes amsterdam one of the most
beautiful cities on earth a hill i'll
die on is that it knows how to iterate
and learn and so whether everything in
the plan comes to be is a separate
matter but whether this city has the
best chance to actually lay down an
ambitious plan and vision for the future
and come close to actually realizing it
that's without question
before you click off i want to say i'm
giving two books away and all you need
to do is be subscribed to this
newsletter on twitter one is in dutch in
amsterdam's
plum it's just you know and the other is
in english on the history of green
wedges i also wanted to say thank you to
yes avis and dr voco as well as any
additional supporters who increase my
ability to take risks while producing
european content the videos are a
constant work in progress and they
aren't at all the quality that i'd like
them to be i like to do so so much more
in terms of 3d and also doing that while
covering undersupplied european stories
so if you want to be able to help me do
that know that any support is incredibly
appreciated